here's the headline headline great
headline guy sells one dollar bills for
fifteen dollars here's how right and so
um here's what he did so he basically
he's 15 years old and he says he sees a
dollar bill on eBay that instead of
who's on the dollar bills Washington or
something like that uh instead of
whoever let's follow George Washington
it's Michael Jordan's face in the middle
right and he orders it because he's like
oh I love Michael Jordan or whatever
this is funny and gets it and it's a
basically it's a normal dollar bill but
then there's just like a sticker paper
over the George Washington and you could
just like do that you could just go to
Office Max and like do this and so
that's exactly what he did he goes to
Office Max he's like I need to be able
to create these because what Better
Business is there to sell dollar bills
for 15
and so he's uh he goes there and then he
goes he puts them up on eBay
[Music]
foreign
what's up
um let's jump in what you got ah you
tell me you I I think I've been driving
the last handful of uh sessions I I I'm
gonna ask you to drive right now
um let's switch gears I want to do
um a topic about you do you I think you
know Mark Jenny you know Mark Jenny Mark
Jenny's a great friend of mine he's he's
an amazing amazing amazing entrepreneur
he's an awesome guy we're going I'm
gonna meet him next week we're going
down to uh stay at one of us he has this
like luxury Airbnb portfolio and you
should follow him on Twitter well you
want me to give his background do you
know his background
I know a little bit of it but go give
the story so if I remember correctly I
think he was raised he had a uh
something was a little wonky with his
childhood I think like he didn't have a
dad or a single single household or
something like that so he wasn't he
wasn't raised in like a very uh
um privileged place and then at one
point I think he was even homeless and
he lived out of like a storage unit or
something like that he started a bunch
of different companies like info
marketing stuff and everything did kind
of okay then he started RV Trader I
believe RV share which was like Airbnb
for RVs he eventually sold a large
portion of it to KKR I think a large PE
company and he probably made many many
tens of millions of dollars a lifetime
of money now he has a new thing that
he's been doing for the last maybe five
or something like that years where he
buys I think he owns 20 of them now he's
got a huge portfolio of airbnbs and
these are high-end luxury homes that
sleep like 20 people it's like two acre
like a two acre plot with like a fancy
four or five six thousand square foot
home with like basketball courts tennis
courts mini Putt-Putt and he's built
this like really really good business
making millions and millions of dollars
renting airbnbs and he's doing it right
and he's got a small team and it's a
proper company not like a side project
yeah I think what is it like a 50
million dollar luxury Airbnb portfolio
at this point yeah I mean I I'm friends
with Mark so he tells me lots of stuff
so I'm trying not to say any of the
numbers because I forget what's public
and what's been private so anything that
you I'll let you actually say any of the
numbers because you're probably getting
it yeah that's just what he tweets out
so you should follow him on Twitter he's
a good follow and it's cool to see like
he'll post like a before and after photo
of these properties he's like here's
what it was and then we added a
McDonald's play place in the backyard
it's like he does like dope stuff like
which I like you know he's not just like
and he's totally unheard of him
he's got like maybe two thousand three
thousand followers on Twitter I think
like he's not like a popular like a like
a big name person so he tweeted this out
the other day and I thought that this
was a great
we haven't done a blue collar side
hustle in a while so I thought this is
kind of a great little almost like a
blue collar side hustle that he he said
he had done I don't know if you saw this
he talked about one of his very first
um like sort of side hustles that he did
or early early hustles was selling
dollar bills for fifteen dollars did you
see this yes yeah go tell us tell the
story so he tweeted this out you can
kind of look at it but here's the
headline headline gray headline guy
sells one dollar bills for fifteen
dollars here's how right and so
um here's what he did so he basically
he's 15 years old and he says he sees a
dollar bill on eBay that instead of
who's on the dollar bills Washington or
something like that uh instead of
whoever let's follow George Washington
it's Michael Jordan's face in the middle
right and he orders it because he's like
oh love Michael Jordan or whatever this
is funny and gets it and it's a
basically it's a normal dollar bill but
then there's just like a sticker paper
over the George Washington and you could
just like do that you could just go to
Office Max and like do this and so
that's exactly what he did he goes to
Office Max he's like I need to be able
to create these because what Better
Business is there to sell dollar bills
for fifteen dollars and so he's uh he
goes there and then he goes he puts him
up on eBay and he first he looked on
eBay and at that time eBay was showing
like how many
um how many items a seller would sell
and he could just keep track of it like
okay this week oh wow they're selling
like you know 100 of these like that's
amazing so he starts doing it he creates
an ebay account
he starts selling these and he starts
averaging a hundred a hundred Bills sold
per day for 15 which includes the
shipping cost General profit was about
1500 a day about 1500 a day he's he's
profiting basically a thousand dollars a
day
um doing this and then he's he ramped it
up and he got it to I think ten thousand
dollars a day and
um in sales and he became the largest
seller of custom novelty collectible
dollar bills on eBay but it's a real
dollar it was a real dollar a real
dollar yeah and if you just add the uh
the sticker on top so you could sell can
you do that legally I guess so why not I
don't know I I don't know there I just
thought there'd be some weird rules
around money no I think you could do it
uh like you know people sell these like
coins and whatever it seems legit so
then what he would do he's like you know
here's how they had to start thinking of
growth hacks how do I beat these other
eBay guys at doing this so what he would
do is he would do one of the auctions
and then he would direct message
everybody who didn't win the auction
offering him the bill at whatever their
highest price was and so
um and so he's like you know what eight
was your top price on it I'll do it for
eight and so he started like just
racking up as many sales as he could
doing this so then he became the top
ranked seller which helped him in the
organic search uh as he was going from
there and I kind of love this and I
loved it for a couple reasons one it's
just another example of these little
nuggets these little stories that shows
you there's a trillion ways to win
there's a trillion ways to get rich
right like he was doing basically 365
000 a year of sales or whatever
um you know he was doing really really
well at that time you know 100 of these
a day what how old was he didn't did you
say he was like this teens he was 15 16
years old that's amazing and
um and you know probably didn't last
forever but these These are these little
Arbitrage opportunities that come up and
then I started thinking okay like what
would somebody do if they're doing that
now so here's I'm gonna give you three
ideas of how you could do that now
first I think you could probably do the
same thing like yeah what's old is new
what's out is in and I think you
probably do the same thing either on
eBay or Etsy or find one of the
marketplaces and you could try to win
doing the same thing I went on Etsy and
actually you could see that there's
people doing this on Etsy right now and
you can see you know how they're how
they're doing so possibly you could go
do the same thing and compete uh
especially if you could pick a different
you know Celebrity Face to put on the
thing like
Trump is the obvious one uh but if it's
not Trump like maybe there's some other
some other ones that you could do but
Trump dollar bills is my first idea of
how I would do this second idea
um okay well let's let's remix it right
we want to keep 80 of the idea we want
to change 20 so what's the 20 change I
would try to piggyback off of whatever's
trending in movies or music or something
like that so for example remember when
super bad came out and there was like
the McLovin
uh you know ID his Hawaii ID the Rainbow
on it's like the same iconic look I
think you could just do McLovin IDs at
that time like if that was the movie
that had come out now I think you could
take a prop from a movie or like in Pulp
Fiction they had the bad mother after
wallet or whatever like I don't know I
had one I don't watch a bunch of movies
now but yeah exactly I wanted one of
those and you could just like jump on
that Trend and be like cool like for the
MC level it's like upload your photo I
will send you yourself as a McLovin ID
and maybe use a little these like AI
things to like create the Avatar where
it looks the same but I think that's one
that you could do really cheap to print
and um and laminate and then you you
know you can send these out very cheaply
because they're they're so thin
um and then I saw some other ones if you
go on Tick Tock you'll see things that
are like this one uh for example I think
the second biggest Etsy store
maybe the first actually now I think
it's second or first on the planet is
this thing called Caitlyn minimalist I'm
guessing you've never heard of this but
no what is this I got a whole thing
coming on the Pod of my Etsy Deep dive
but but I'll just give you a little
sneak peek the top selling stores
Caitlyn minimalist and what she does was
how she got her break was she was like
she was making jewelry for herself her
friends were like oh that's cool then
her friend had a special request she
goes my mom or dad passed away I forgot
which one
um and like the last thing they wrote me
was like this note
is it possible to like get their
signature in their handwriting as like a
bracelet and she's like yeah you just
like I could do that for you and she
gave it to her for free she was like
this is so meaningful to you I'll just
give it to you for free
and she was like overwhelmed was like
this is the most meaningful thing in the
world and so
she was like oh wow people just want
like you know their name their parents
name their kid's name and ideally in
their own handwriting like done in
jewelry and so that's what how do you do
that you like send her or is it all
digital you like yeah you sent her a
picture or you write the name you know
it depends if you want to match the
handwriting you got to send a picture of
the of this of like a piece of paper
with the writing on it and there's some
tech that just then like tells her like
etches it in that look right so it's not
like made out of metal it's a metal
plaque or like a it's like a dog tag and
then she like no no it is it's cut it's
like the name is cut and it's like
whatever like yeah it is like you know
whatever somehow somehow I don't know
exactly her manufacturing process but
these little like Custom Custom name
things I think work and um I was on Tick
Tock yesterday when I was thinking about
this idea how big is it oh it's huge
she's done like probably 80 90 million
in sales is my oh my God so she's done
two million transactions I would guess
her average transactions like you know
something 40 50 bucks something like
that so yeah that's like 80 million
dollars and sales Lifetime and um
she's just like this woman out of LA or
whatever and um I was on Tick Tock and I
was scrolling and I saw another one of
these which was
um you it was a hoodie it was like
here's a perfect gift for the holidays
or for Valentine's Day or whatever it's
a hoodie and they're like take a picture
of you and your whatever your boyfriend
girlfriend spouse whatever and it
basically takes like let's say it's a
picture of you and your wife and you're
kissing and it just like it'll etch
it'll Stitch like a silhouette of that
yeah it's like into the hoodie so it's
like a meaningful gift but again it's
like this kind of what they call Mass
customization right so if you can do
Mass customization if you could figure
out a manufacturing process to do this
there's a lot of opportunity to sell
somebody these like kind of gimmick
gifts that I think will uh that can and
will work do you remember uh Teespring
Teespring yeah it was like the print on
demand type of yeah it was a really cool
t-shirt company started by this guy
named Walker Williams and they were like
one of these companies that was like oh
this is gonna be one of the fastest
companies ever to get to 100 million in
revenue and the way that they got
popular was it was on-demand t-shirt
printing
and they figured out this hack on
Facebook where you could Target people
that have your like by last name so it
could be like the one thing we all know
about Smith's is that they love to party
or they also did by location like the
one thing we know about people who are
raised in Boston is that they love blank
and they had a t-shirt that said I'm
from Boston and I'm proud or I'm from
Boston and I love blank or I'm a proud
Smith or something like that
and the engagement on those ads was
crazy so their CAC was like stupid low
and that's one of the ways that they
grew and it's just like that it's that
uh thing from Dale Carnegie the most
beautiful word in any language is the
person's name right and I think it's
like name location and maybe like where
you went to school and then followed by
like your friends names and if you could
figure out how to like incorporate those
into ads or the click-through rate is
crazy Pet's face so there's another one
which is pet socks pets face on socks I
think I have a pair jungle Creations was
the name of it so if I remember
correctly at one point they did like a
million dollars in like a week selling
you'd basically go on the website you'd
upload a photo of your pet's face and
they would print it on socks and they
would just drop ship that to you
basically and
um let me see if I can find uh
yeah they did 2018 they did 17 million
in Revenue
um
they did 17 million in Revenue doing
basically pet pet face on socks right
and so that's the same thing you know
Celebrity Face on dollar bill pet face
on socks right like we have a buddy who
is doing the uh Pet Portraits right like
a painting of your pet that would just
be like mass mass customized uh produced
there's there's a ton of these like
little opportunities yeah and the
click-through rates on these things are
like kill it for the ads so yeah I yeah
that's an interesting idea let's see if
anyone actually follows through with it
I I but Mark Jenny's amazing man he's
awesome all right so let me break them
one thing up
um
dude this guy made fun of me the other
day for having a course
and it hurt my friend or a internet
stranger
uh a little bit of both and it really
hurt my feelings do you feel like
because all right so I built a business
before I built a few businesses before
so a few that I've got the seven figures
a few that I've gotten eight figures
I've sold things I should feel confident
about this
and then you and I both have courses I'm
gonna actually launch another course
that I think can be like a like a
million dollar plus a year income stream
for me and my family which is awesome
it's never good when you have to say for
me and my family like if you have to
justify feeding your family that means
uh there's that's just the insecurity
poking out
poking out of there well it gives
context and what I mean is is it the
content the question that I'm gonna ask
is is it worth it because part of me
thinks well if I'm such a big shot I
shouldn't talk about it I should just
have [__] and not teach it but then I'm
like but I like doing it and it's a
significant like it pays for my whole
life so do you yeah if you again the
only question I was gonna ask do you
like it you like doing it yeah all right
that's enough right like but do you feel
like you feel like a fraud sometimes too
or at least I you've never said that to
me but you said that when we had when we
were interviewing that one person you're
like I kind of feel like
a fraud every once in a while or I
forget what you said not a fraud but um
I do feel like I make fun of myself
about the course thing
um because same thing self-conscious
Maybe
self-conscious is a better word yeah
yeah yeah like you know I would say
somebody who is like
somebody who is really locked in and I
use the word locked in because it's not
about how much money you have uh like
but it's true somebody who's really
really wealthy would not
do a paid course I don't think I don't
think somebody who's like super wealthy
probably should be or would be doing
paid courses pretty unusual to do well I
I think that's definitely wrong though
because like Warren Buffett had a course
at Columbia I mean there's a lot of
examples of like wonderful investors who
go and they uh I don't think Warren
Buffett did his course for like I don't
think he was pocketing a bunch of money
doing a direct sales course type of
thing like I if I went and taught a
guest if I was a guest lecturer at
Stanford right I drove 45 minutes away I
go guest lecture at Stanford I'm a
teacher there I would be doing that for
different reasons and it would feel
totally differently than me being like
hey I have my power writing course go
sign up and pay for it
um I don't know why it is it's just
different it's a different thing but I
would say two things I said locked in
because also
if you have like a main thing that is
totally
uh an obsession for you you're you're
loving working on it there's so much
there's more to do than you'll ever have
time to do you really wouldn't take the
time to stop pause and go
um so of course it's my opinion about
myself I should say I would not go do
that so to me as long as I'm still doing
courses it's me part of my wandering
around phase trying to figure out what I
really want to do when I grow up what I
want to do with my life what I want to
do with my time I know that if I get
locked in on oh man I really love this
project I'm just building Brick by Brick
this is something that I'm really
excited about there's no chance in hell
that I would Push pause and teach scores
even though my courses are like it's two
weeks out of the year so it's not a lot
of time but even even those two weeks I
probably wouldn't do if I was in that
position in the same way that when I was
building my startup I had no podcast I
Had No Angel Investing I had no courses
I didn't do I didn't tweet I didn't do
[__] when I was building my startup for
like seven years because I was fully
locked in on that it's only after we
sold that I started doing a bunch of
these things and that became the new the
new business was the podcast and other
things I think I'm going to keep doing
it
um but I think you should totally keep
doing it you said you like it so keep
doing it
let me share a little thing I do it
during my course because during the
course of the uh the writing course some
people will be like
you know okay I get like uh this lesson
was really great I feel like I now have
a much better idea how I would write to
like kind of go viral or build my brand
there's a part of me that just feels
like you know they'll ask a question
that's like
how much content would you say is too
much you know so it's too much to post
or would you say that like you know I
should wait you know until my product
launches to start doing content or like
they ask all these questions that are
sort of like self-promotey and uh
self-conscious feelings self-conscious
there's just under there's just a layer
of self-consciousness around the whole
thing or like you know what do you what
do you say if you post something and
then somebody comments do you take it
down blah blah blah do you you know how
do you deal with you know a negativity
or blah blah
and I always just say the same thing I
go
like oh I'm gonna answer you a question
but hey what what time is it I want to
make sure we don't go over what time is
it and then they're like uh 9 34. I'm
like no no it's me o'clock you forgot
that it's me o'clock
um you know you're thinking about what
everybody else might think what they
might say and how they might feel and
what my bro you forgot the main thing
it's always me o'clock you just got to
ask yourself do I like this do I want to
do this how do I feel about doing this
remember it is always me o'clock in fact
I want to get watches made or a clock on
my wall that just just reminds me it is
me o'clock should I wait to go do this
thing no it's me o'clock should I care
what other people are thinking no it's
me o'clock how do I feel that's what I'm
gonna do things based off dude there's
this funny picture of Fidel Castro you
know like the the dictator of Cuba and
he's wearing two Rolexes at the same
time both of the same wrist just because
he's just like he just wants to flex
that hard
you need to get two watches on each bad
that say wait just let me make sure this
other one's not broken
yeah that's exactly how I feel dude so
your question to me I don't even need to
answer I just got to remind you it's me
o'clock you do it you know what the hell
you want
um all right you have another thing on
here that was like
the 10 list yeah the list I I'm gonna
read the title and you you go from there
so it just says a few non-popular things
I've learned from this pot pretty good
headline eight out of ten thank you
we'll accept I'm gonna say each one and
I want you to give me your reaction and
then I'll explain a little more context
but all right the first one well can you
give context on the whole thing like
where did this come from or what why did
you even think of this list of because
unpopular things you've learned from the
Pod I see a lot of things online of
people talking where they try to explain
uh like rules like you do have to work
this much or you don't have to work this
much or and the reality is is that uh
there's a million ways to get the same
things done so like for every example of
one person succeeding in one way there's
gonna be lots of examples of them
succeeding a totally different way so I
think it's silly to have rules and so I
like will see these things of people
posting of like oh you know like they
say it's a 10-year overnight success and
in my head I think
man I know people who have had overnight
successes were like literally in three
months their life has changed and I
think it's silly to not acknowledge that
you know and so that's how I kind of
came up with this list uh okay all right
hit me I'm excited now all right the
first one I just said so an overnight
success which is like one or six months
it's absolutely possible and those those
exist and they're real agree or disagree
all right give us an example for example
uh we covered this company called
brewmate
b-r-u-m-a-t-e and the I think in like
year two they got the 20 million in
Revenue in year one they got to like
eight million and I know a few people
that have had other companies were like
in the first six months like it kind of
just took off and it worked uh so we
interviewed who else did we interview
um well you're I would say your current
stealth company we haven't talked about
yet
taken off right away yeah it succeeded
like pretty quickly and how do you count
that do you count that overnight success
or do you say I've been preparing my
whole life for this right that's the
that's the account argument I'll say
like I built up a reputation and I'm
trading off that reputation but there
are times you and I have like talked to
people for example we uh I had this guy
on who you weren't here but you know him
his name's Val do you know Val v a l Val
he had a company where in year one it
made like 10 million in profit and it
was selling like ringtones on the
internet and like just some people just
have the it factor and then also like
luck is real so that's another thing
luck is real sometimes you just kind of
nail it and it just works not always and
most of the time it doesn't but every
once in a while it just happens and so I
think for people to say overnight
success isn't real I think that that's
nonsense because I I know a handful of
people who are like 19 20 year old kids
who they like within a few months
they've got something making many many
tens or sometimes hundreds of thousands
of dollars a month in sales and it just
works yeah yeah I'm with you on that I
agree
um all right here's another one I think
at least in the beginning of your career
where you live it actually really really
matters it's incredibly important and
the people who don't move some places I
think they are at a disadvantage
100 agree uh I did this I was sitting in
Australia and I wanted to do startups
and I was go I went to a local startup
like event
and I was like okay
um I'm like looking around everybody's
being super nice right it's Australia
everybody gets along great and I just
thought in my head I go who's the most
successful entrepreneur in this room and
it was this one old ass [__] who
was like you know had built something in
the 90s and he just like stuck around
and then nobody else pretty much and
then I was asking some questions I was
talking and something and they got the
organizer was like dude you should give
a talk next next month at the Meetup
like this is great we would love to have
you teach and I was like teach I'm 23
I've done nothing I was like if and I
like At first I was flattered and then I
caught myself two seconds later I was
like oh wait this just means I'm in the
wrong Pond I do not want to be a smart
guy in the room they should be like dude
you should shut up you don't know
anything about anything that's the type
of room I want to be in and so I
literally went home I went on I think
like T-Mobile or whatever I activated a
a phone plan and I got a 650 area number
area code because cause I was like I
need to just mentally before I even move
I need to go to Silicon Valley now so I
changed my phone number and then I
booked a ticket and my mom was like you
know what are you gonna where are you
gonna stay do you have a job I was like
I don't know I'm gonna figure it out but
I'll I have a better shot of figuring it
out there than I do from here and that
was my whole mindset and Tony Robbins
has a thing he says about this he goes
proximity Is Power and I am a huge
believer that proximity Is Power I have
done pretty crazy things to just get in
proximity of people that I think are
awesome like I will take jobs that I
think are like the worst job of all the
job offers I have if I know that it's
going to get me to sit side by side with
somebody awesome because I know six
months next to that person is gonna do
more for me than uh you know like a
better higher paying job would have done
and so proximity Is Power I'm big this
goes beyond business it's Beyond
business it's just anything if you want
to make it in the movie industry you
have a higher likelihood if you at least
spend a handful of you years early on in
Hollywood just putting in the time
matters you know if there's like these
funny stories about Bill Murray who
lives in like North Carolina or
something and he's like totally out of
the loop it's like yeah that that that
definitely works there are examples of
that but I think it increase your odds
yeah you want to increase your odds of
success the second one or the third one
luck is is incredibly real you know I
remember like early on in my career I
was thinking like there is no such thing
as luck it's just hard work and I'm just
gonna do it
no shit's real shit's real I remember I
I've said the story a bunch of times but
when we were selling our company Brian
Halligan the CEO of HubSpot at the time
got in a life-threatening accident two
weeks after we closed and there's a
world where two weeks before if it
happened it could have ruined it I think
you've had a couple examples where if
one or two things happened before or
after selling a business like it like
within like a month it could have
changed things uh getting sick really
matters being born like in a healthy
place in a healthy family like things
like that luck is totally real and I
think that we dismiss it too often yeah
I think uh I agree with that I would say
luck is real I would also say a big part
of luck is in your control and a small
part of luck is out outside of your
control so most of the luck you
experience in your life there's a whole
bunch of things at the beginning being
born in a certain place healthy your
parents whatever those are outside of
your control a lot of what happens after
that is in your control and we've done
the there's a podcast episode called
four levels of luck where we talk uh you
know on framework Friday we talk about
actually manipulating left to be to go
towards your advantage if that makes
sense there is a set of actions you can
take that will increase the amount of
luck you end up having in your life uh
and this is not like you know hold
crystals or something like that it's
like more practical uh tangible stuff
um okay the last part of that that I'll
say is
I remember when I was
I had moved to San Francisco and I met
Michael Birch the guy I came to work
with because again proximity's power I
just took the job because I was like oh
I get to sit next to this guy this guy's
like a billionaire who's built four
successful internet companies well what
is the thing I want to do build a
successful internet company I think this
is the place to sit
and I was talking to him and I was
trying to figure out like did this guy
just get lucky or what happened
because a lot of people I think would
look at him and say oh he got lucky
because the thing he sold
two years later [__] he sold it for 850
million dollars two years later a year
later AOL wrote it off for like you know
a giant tax write-off and just like and
nobody uses bibo now Facebook one and it
Facebook Beat It and so some people say
oh he got lucky right you know he sold
it for whatever
and I definitely don't think that's true
because he's built like multiple
companies that have been successful
but what I figured out what I the the
thing I ended figuring out was it's not
lucky that he won but it is lucky how
much he won so he was going to be
successful either way but whether that
number was 20 million 80 million or 800
million there was a large degree of luck
and timing that was outside of his
control that contributed to that he
could just easily just as easily have
been an 80 million Guy versus an 800
million guy and that I don't think was
necessarily in his control that was
right place right right time right
circumstances you know the right person
had the right drinks at the right bar
next to the right person and I think
that you know the magnitude of success
is a lot more based on luck not the uh
appearance of six not the not the um
existence of the success he was going to
be successful no matter what all right
and I'm going to jump around another one
ivy league ish school so I don't know
how we're going to Define that but like
the top 20 University uh is totally
worth it what even if that means that
you have to go into a lot of debt I
think it's totally worth it I think
State schools where you get some type of
in-state tuition and you still get a
college experience totally worth it most
everything in between if you have to go
into debt for it I think it's absolutely
not worth it
like where I went to school when I went
I went to Belmont University I was I was
fortunate I got a little bit of a
scholarship and my parents paid for for
it uh 100 not worth it it was at the
time I think 30 or 40 Grand a year and
it's a no-name university that it does
it's just completely irrelevant 100 not
worth it but I know people who went to
my wife went to an Ivy League school I
know people like you went to Duke and
like you have a handful of connections
if you go to Stanford you have all these
connections that seem 100 worth it and
here's another like thing if you have
Stanford on your resume you're gonna at
least get the interview this is true if
you look at how people recruit they just
gotta scroll through an Excel sheet and
it just says where you graduated
Bellarmine in Kentucky that cost sixty
thousand dollars a year or whatever it
is that is not the same as Stanford or
Dartmouth like you're just automatically
going to have an increased likelihood of
getting that interview but even more
important than that you're going to meet
people who are have been maybe been
around the world have Rich parents like
that stuff actually matters and act
actually those connections and that that
influence on your life it really
actually matters and it's worth going
into debt I
kind of disagree here so I went to Duke
which is not not technically an Ivy
League school but is like considered up
there with with ivy league is actually
like a sports thing but like you know
whatever it's considered like a top
school and it wasn't worth it for me
because I was not ready to figure out
how to make it worth it right it's it's
what you make of it it is not gonna be
handed to you just by showing up and I
had the total I had totally the wrong
mindset I thought I'm here I gotta I
don't know do the thing I've been doing
to get here get good grades
um you know eventually graduate pass the
test you know go to med school do
whatever I'm supposed to do it was like
a track
and there are some people who made it
worth it the people who were like yo we
got these resources for free or I'm
gonna go and meet these these two
professors or I'm gonna get exposure to
these other classes that I want to learn
about or I'm going to use my time here
to socialize plus spin up some side
hustles because man there's no better
time to find co-founders and build a
startup than when you're in college like
there were some people who had that
right mindset the light my light bulb is
not on right like now I got this
floating ass light bulb there was no
there was no light bulb on at that time
and so I misused it I think the majority
of people misuse it
I did have one phone call that was
really important and I'm just gonna say
it out loud here because if there's
somebody who needs to hear this you know
I got lucky that my dad gave me this
phone call maybe your maybe your dad
doesn't have the same sort of wisdom
that my mine did so I'm going to say it
out loud I called my dad my second year
into college and I was like hey um
he's like how's it going and I was like
I don't know it's okay he's like what do
you mean like how's your you know how
school and I was like well
grades aren't great he's like oh man
what happened I was like no they're not
terrible I'm not failing I just like you
know I'm a B minus student here and like
you know I've been getting A's in high
school so B minus was like no not very
good he's like all right that's all
right um he's like are you trying and I
was like yeah I'm trying but man like
everybody here is smart like you know
everybody here is just as smart as me if
not smarter and they all work harder
than me and I'm trying to figure out
this whole hard work thing but like you
know I'm just gonna be honest with you
it's like these guys just live in the
library and I just don't even like I
just figured out where they go they go
to the library they go to office I was
like I was I didn't even understand
where people were going with their free
time that's what they were doing was
your dad paying yeah parents would pay
for it so this is what I told him I go
you know you're paying a lot of money
for me to go here and uh you know I
could go to UT you know State School
it'd be I think 10 times cheaper or
something like that like five times
cheaper maybe I was like you know if you
want me to try like I'm willing to
transfer by the way just because like I
don't think I'm gonna do that well here
and so I don't think it's worth it for
you to pay this amount of money and so I
told him that and he goes
um and but I had been telling him he's
like he goes why do you say that you
know
um you're not like good there and I was
like well like dude my my this guy who
lives next door to me he's like a
freaking genius he's like you know he
just gets the physics stuff right away
and then he's also good outside of class
like you know in the Summers he goes and
he drives a ambulance in the Palestinian
War Front just for fun and like if
that's how he spends his Summers like
I'm over here picking boogers with you
like you know I don't even know what to
do in the summer these guys all got
plans and internships and and this and
that and like this guy's Uncle works at
JP Morgan he's doing that thing and I
was like and he goes yeah that's the
point because that's why you're there
you're not there for the classes you're
there because when everybody around you
is like that it will just raise your
standards you won't even know what
mediocre looks like you think you're
mediocre but that's because you're
hanging out with exceptional people if I
take you and put you in a state school
you're not going to have as many
exceptional people around you who for
them that's normal and he goes so you
know the point of being in college for
you to go to that school is not so you
could graduate at the top of the class
and get the best grades and be the
smartest kid in this in the classes it's
so that that becomes your network and
that becomes your normal and he's
basically said something to that effect
so you've proven my point by the way
it's pretty deep you're kind of proving
my point I know I know so I'm saying
like that is the the Saving Grace of it
I don't know if the
um I don't know like that light bulb
went on for me halfway through then I
started to focus on oh yeah then once I
realized that I started to get to know
those people before that I was like oh
these just they're just different I'ma
stay away and like I don't know I gotta
find people who are like me who are just
basically bumming around here who don't
know what to do instead I was like oh
the point is to be hanging out with
these people and become more like them
and not feel like I'm competing with
them or intimidated by them all right
I've got a few more and I'm gonna
actually merge a couple of them so uh um
another one having a technical skill if
we're talking about internet companies
it this mostly means like being able to
like code or design
uh in my case it was writing which
actually I think counts but it's a
little bit less more important but
having a technical skill like in
training to have a skill set is a
massive massive advantage and I think
being a generalist is not that is just a
[__] excuse but you should actually
be good at at least one thing and right
particularly coding or design would be
better but copywriting counts as well
and there's a few other things sales
actually I think can count but you need
to be good at something and I think that
most people don't do something you need
to be great at something you gotta like
train for years to acquire a skill and
then go beyond that but you need a skill
and I think it's a massive advantage and
people dismiss that as being a
generalist and that's just like self
masturbation that is a bull crap excuse
in reality you should be you should try
to get great at something you know
what's the funniest version of a
generalist so generalist already is like
you're teetering on the edge of just
being a bullshitter yeah it's people who
call themselves a polymath have you ever
heard somebody call them that's [__]
dude yes that's like people who call
themselves a contrarians like dude if
you gotta label it you're probably not
it you you can't be the one who calls
yourself a polymath nor could you call
yourself a country it's other people who
got to point it out that's when that
label works it's like you can't nickname
nickname yourself brain that doesn't it
doesn't work that way you know you gotta
you you either you either
yeah no no that's not how that worked
other people can call you humble you
don't get to call yourself yeah so
polymath is like the you've you've
you've fallen over the fence like Humpty
Dumpty and now you're fully in [__]
land
um when you're calling yourself a
polymath so okay that's my that's my
rant on that I think you're 100 right
you gotta have some ski what do we say
you gotta have some attributes yeah you
got to break some attributes man you
gotta have some side strength time you
gotta have attributes you can't just be
a dope I hired a guy that I thought was
gonna be great because he was like you
know saying all the right he was
hustling he was saying all the right
things and within a month I realized
guy's got no attributes he's gotta have
some extra what are you good at what can
you do oh man I can help with anything
okay you can help with anything what can
you what problem can you go solve what
what are you great at if I hand you this
thing what can you just nail this part
of it
I I would also consider myself somewhat
of a generalist but it's you can only
real what people mean when they're
actually a good version of a generalist
is they're great at one thing but they
decided not to just specialize as that
yeah that one tool for the rest of their
life and they've decided to go broader
but they got that in their back pocket
one or two core skills they're amazing
at paid marketing they're amazing at
copywriting they're amazing at building
at you know coding they're amazing at
um sales and they could just do that as
their job and they could be you know in
the top 10 percent of people if they did
that just as their job not the top one
percent right because they're not sure
specializing and being like I'm gonna
hone this craft every day for the rest
of my life but they're in the top 10
already at that and then they're in the
top like 30 at four or five other things
that's a real generalist not somebody
who's just
average at everything and like we're
good at nothing or good at nothing right
yeah what did uh Ronda Rousey call it a
DNB you remember that what's that mean
she go she goes she was talking about
this when she was on the top and in the
UC and she she goes all these other
girls are just dnbs they just do nothing
[__] and I was like wow that is an
incredible phrase and so in my head when
I hear a generalist I'm like let me make
sure you're actually not just a DNB
um yeah dude a dude nothing [__] like
you need to do something and or like in
your case your skill set could actually
be like Charisma and like attracting and
recruiting people and like putting in
the right direction that that's a skill
set you know leadership is a skill set
uh getting things started that that and
being like the the the initial match
that gets like a fire started I think
that's a skill set but I think having a
skill and like actually being great at
something that's really important all
right I'll give you a few more
um
assume that people don't change I think
that's like a safe that's like a safe
rule you know we we have this attitude
maybe it's an American thing I don't
know where it's just like you can change
and I do believe that's possible you
know I've had demons in the past that
I've overcome I know a lot of other
people who have had things that they've
overcome that [__] does take place it's
fairly rare and if you are a person that
talks the talk and you don't walk the
walk
you will never change and if I meet
someone like that I just assume oh
they're just always going to be like
that and they will not change no amount
of encouragement is going to make them
change sometimes that happens assume
it won't and that's I used to have a
different attitude when I started my
company I'm like oh I'll just get these
people and I'll teach them how to be
great yada yada yada as I've grown with
this pod and talk to people I just the
people who act a certain way have always
acted that way yeah there's uh my sister
says that she goes no no people change
for the worse like like
they will Decay more often than
they'd be like turning it around and
like you know going from A to B and so I
think you're right that is the working
assumption unto you know innocent until
proven guilty you know same till proven
different is how I feel with people
right you exactly you gotta show that
something is changing I am not going to
assume and I'm not going to be that you
know the the stereotypical like the
woman who wants to fix him it's like
don't I'm not that I'm I don't want to
be that when I recruit people anymore no
I'd rather just recruit people who are
great
and like just let them do their thing
versus somebody that I'm gonna train and
groom and turn around a project it's
like why do all that effort no bonus
points for making it harder
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
all right the last two so I actually
don't think necessarily that the time
and effort put into a project is going
to dictate the outcome I think to get
like uh to build like a company no I
would have to like put numbers on it to
build a company that like makes you
potentially worth hundreds of millions
of dollars in some cases
you don't necessarily have you you can
achieve that by having balance but I
think to have these massive outsized
world-changing companies things that
create tens of billions of dollars in 10
15 years and have a meaningful impact in
the world like a Tesla or something
crazy like that
um or a stripe something like that
I think that working 80 hours a week
raising lots and lots of money and
having zero balance is 100 needed that
said I think you can still achieve a
huge amount of success compared to the
average Joe and actually do it working
40 hours a week or in some cases after a
while less and uh that's like an
interesting dichotomy but I think it's
to be I think it's true yeah I'll go
with that I like that uh what else you
got any one more
last one
and this is like an e this is one of the
very few irreversible decisions so
having some type of success and taking a
meaningful amount of risk before you
have a family meaning you have less time
you've got less responsibility
unfortunately it's an irresponsible
irreversible decision but getting an
early-ish win early in your career is
100 a huge advantage and you are at a
massive disadvantage by having a young
family and not having like achieved
something and then wanting to go achieve
it it's not impossible but like taking
those risks early on people should be
encouraged to do that more because it is
life-changing yeah I think so the um
Paul Graham has this essay that he wrote
I don't remember the name of it but he
basically was like assume I forgot the
exact metrics I read this a long time
ago I was in my early 20s and I like
stood out to me he was like um
assume you start out with seven points
as an entrepreneur and these are your
set the seven points is like your
capacity to like take risks and like
achieve what you want
and then he's like for every one of
these things like you know minus one
right it's like mortgage and whatever
minus one kids minus two
um you know and he's basically like you
know you can still do it but you your
margin of error and the difficulty that
you're gonna have and the stress and the
stress you're gonna have pulling this
off like assume you are sort of sapping
your your you know your life Mana your
your points uh in terms of how much ammo
you have to go attack this thing it's
being sapped by each one of these these
factors and um I don't remember what all
of them were but it's worth you know go
go and find this essay because I think
it's actually true it's an uncomfortable
truth people don't like this because it
doesn't sound politically correct
because like you know the politically
correct thing to say is you can do it
you could do anything and
um and you could argue and you should by
the way if you're 40 you shouldn't be
listening to this part you should be
saying
screw that I got all the wisdom I got my
purpose my kids I got the experience oh
you know that a 20 year old will never
have I have and yes you have different
advantages
but objectively speaking it is much
easier to take risks and if you were
gonna just play it out in an ideal
scenario you would take your risks
earlier when you have less to lose you
have less pressure less stress less
Financial Obligations it's just a more
like Game Theory optimal way to play you
don't have to play it that way but it is
I think sort of objectively speaking in
a a a preferred way to play but you know
if you didn't play that way it's okay
you can still win anyways so that's the
list that's my unpopular truths my my
not awesome stuff to discuss but I
believe it to be true that I've learned
from the Pod and I'll end with all of
those rules or whatever I describe them
as can be completely broken and there's
tons of examples of all of them being
not true but yeah that's what I believe
to be true so that's my list
okay I like it um let me give you
another idea all right so
uh I was doing do you do like gifs like
company gifts for the holiday or
something like that do you like send out
gifts no no that wasn't that wasn't a me
thing do you are you doing the warm
tender person who might that you know
give giving up my love language bro
words of affirmation are
[Laughter]
odds of approval yeah yeah
a pat on the back is the greatest gift
the greatest gift is the lack of
criticism that I provided you today
um
so I was thinking about it I was like oh
you know and I remember at a you know at
a previous company I worked at the the
office manager she was good at the stuff
and she would get like everybody's
address and then she would send these
Harry and David gift gift baskets have
you ever had a Harry and David gift
basket no what's that oh dude imagine
somebody's at the door who could it be
you go to the door
uh hey we have this amazing huge gift
basket for you you take it into your
kitchen you're like wow what's what's
gonna be in this gift basket Sam take a
guess what's in this gift basket
chocolate I guess could be chocolate
could have been chocolate it's not
chocolate though what else could it be
uh like Local Foods like bricks of
salami and cheese it could be sloppy
cheese there's a little bit of that
there's a little bit of chocolate
there's a little bit of cheese in there
pears they had these jumbo pears and
they know because pears are the most
underrated fruit they are the official
fruit of my first million as far as I'm
concerned it's huge delicious pears were
in there and I was like what the hell
and I was like
giant gift that I received and why does
it why is it so awesome it's called The
Blend Harry and David Perry and David
right so so they they do gift baskets of
all kinds but this one was a giant pear
basket that we got and I still remember
this thing and I was dude you came over
to my house I don't care if you're the
the cleaner you're just a guy walking by
I was slinging pears to you because I
had the juiciest pairs that were gonna
go bad they were massive and I needed to
offload these things and everybody asked
oh wow where'd you get this I said my
company sent it to me because they love
me and that's how I felt and so I
thought I I always remember this
experience and so then I started digging
I was like what's up with this Harry
David thing by the way oh man and
they're huge Harry and David sold to a
company that you know of 1-800 Flowers
for 142 million dollars back in 2014.
they have a couple you know main brands
of this the guy Harry and David which is
these gift baskets they have wolferman
which is Gourmet English muffins and
other foods like that and they have
Stockyards which is you know Prime you
know Prime Meats basically
um and Harry David it's a super seasonal
business fall and winter is when they
get a lot of their orders and um
they got 50 retail stores that like you
know help them fill the stuff and it got
me thinking about Harry David it got me
think about 100 flowers I did a little
Deep dive so 100 flowers starts off as a
phone number 42 years ago literally it
was just 100 flowers and it goes on to
build basically like a 600 million
dollar plus business they you know for a
long time it's just a phone number then
1985 they start e-commerce because
they're like oh we need this and they
basically have like thousands of
locations and fulfillment centers not
all owned by them but like fulfillment
Partners somebody who can send flowers
to you and um you know basically these
guys are it's like four it's like a
bundle of 14 Brands and let me just give
you their their revenue last quarter so
they're publicly Trader yeah what's that
publicly traded they did 485 million in
Revenue uh last quarter so that that
means they're now a um what what is that
500 times well and that's not even a
popular quarter probably probably their
February Revenue like Trump's like the
the the yeah the Winter's probably their
biggest but let's say it's probably a
billion and a half a year is is pretty
pretty safe to say uh the gift baskets
which are the Harry and David section
they're doing they did 148 Million last
quarter so that means that's probably
like a 500 million dollar your business
um florals was 300 million and then
um yeah basically they have like
whatever they have some other stuff
they got Cheryl's Cookies they bought
her for 40 million they got um you know
personalization mail which is something
I don't know they bought for 250 million
they got Sherry's Berries you know
Cherries Berries berries yeah right it's
great popcorn factories bought that for
30 million back in the day so they own
all these Brands so I'm like okay this
is great
now I've also been doing this food
gifting thing lately because
I'm like you I'm not a big gifter trying
to get better at it inspired by our
buddy Ramon and who is a prolific gifter
the best
Savage of a gift
um so he got me thinking man he really
highlighted my gifting deficiencies so I
said all right I'm gonna start sending
gifts but I'm not a big plan ahead guy
so
day of where do you get a last minute
gift that can get to that person's house
same day same hour maybe maybe it's 11
p.m I'm trying to squeeze it in before
midnight
doordash and ubereats that's what I've
been doing I will just doordash you food
because food is you know the universal
love language yeah but what are you
gonna do send me a pizza at 11 A.M
that's stupid I'll send you a pizza and
wings I'll send you
four slushies I'll send you boba tea
I'll send you a Cinnabon I'll send you
bro I got options I got I got a whole
like menu of my gifting foods that I'll
go to because I gotta know and I gotta
know what you like right like I know you
got that sweet tooth right I might hit
you with 16 pints of ice cream and
you'll be like this is Sean this is
simply too much ice cream I'll be like I
know because I love you that much right
so I'll just hit you with these kind of
these kind of gifts so
I think that somebody should build a
1-800 Flowers type of brand because the
things I'm gifting they're not made for
this they're not made to be gifted right
the Cinnabon is not made to be sent to a
friend for their birthday but I think
somebody should build basically birthday
eats or last minute gifts on doordash on
I completely agree as a cloud kitchen
I'm just getting stronger as the idea
builds uh as a cloud kitchen Nationwide
it is optimized for gifts so baskets
that are nicely like put a bow on it
um handwritten notes that's got to be a
part of it uh you know so something
that's going to be able to give you a
note or even a little like little
trinket that shows that this is a card
that this is for the occasion and then
help me help you help me get to somebody
else is how I feel about this now the
cloud kitchen is already good but if you
remember back in the day we had the idea
of not just a cloud kitchen but a clout
Kitchen where you partner with a
celebrity so this is where I need your
help we need our celebrity partner who
is going to be the face
of this last minute gifts brand this
Gourmet gifts brand that we're going to
create launch Nationwide across ubereats
it sounds it comes to mind it sounds
like a rhetorical question so I have a
feeling you have someone in mind don't
do it honestly only person I thought of
was Ryan Seacrest and I don't even know
why
I might as well go with the hardest
working man in Hollywood I haven't seen
his face in that app I think he would
like to be in that app so I'm thinking
Ryan Seacrest is a good guy white women
like you you'd be fine universally
universally not hated
you know like a recognizable face
um but who else could be who else could
be the guy or the gal like you know
Mariah Carey she's seasonal maybe
Mariah's maybe Mariah is is is maybe she
needs to get out of the song game and
get into the gift game I I I I don't
know but I do think this is actually
brilliant I've tried to order one I'm a
last minute gift guy too and I'll try to
order 1-800 Flowers the the morning of
Valentine's Day and they and oftentimes
they don't let you you know they're just
like it's too late if you really loved
her you would have done this three days
ago yeah and it's a it's super annoying
so I'm totally on board I I I I I I
think this is awesome I think this is
this is this is great
um can you not do that now there aren't
any good gift basket companies
like if I open doordash right now so
let's let's open this I can't get an
Edible Arrangement also a great gift man
Edible Arrangements wonderful yeah those
are good and I think you can get some of
those but I think we need a fresh brand
so like
like you know they have like they have
the Flower and Gift Boutique on mine at
least
um
and it's flowers You Know It's Just
Flowers right like it's like roses a
cookie in a bag right yeah a bath bomb
come on come on you think Mariah and
Ryan Seacrest are just gonna lose to
this
no It's gotta be extravagant
I I'm on board I I I've experienced the
same thing and I've also studied 1-800
Flowers 1-800 Flowers is a really
interesting company because they will
tell you all types of insights in their
annual report and they have so much
Intel because they own so many Brands so
I'll give an example and one of their
reports they said succulents are growing
amongst Millennials and I remember
reading about that like in 2018 and I
told a couple people about it and they
started succulent delivery businesses
geared towards Millennials and they kill
it you know there's now the the sill
there's another one called uh what's
that other one called
dude and they have so much insights or
another Insight that you can get from
100 flowers is they're like we're trying
to they're what do they say they go we
actually don't make a lot of money from
flowers but we make a shitload of money
from like when people buy vases so I'm
like why aren't you like painting cool
[__] on this vase and getting people to
like spend more money on it you know
like why why don't I see like a Frida
Kahlo or whoever it is like painting on
like this like sick vase and I'll pay
you 50 for it right uh dude 1-800
Flowers is actually a really really
really good business to go and read
their annual reports because they have
such interesting insight and they've
been doing it for I don't know how old
is it now it's from the 70s I think
um and so really interesting company of
study I love that business I love the
gifting business
but their market cap sucks why is their
market cap so bad their market cap is
600 million dollars is it really
yeah it's horrible they just like
plummeted over the past uh well I guess
everything has plummeted but it's been
really bad over the past year
that's interesting I wonder if they
think they're getting like you know
disrupted by something yeah yeah 600
million is the market cap that sounds
and the guy who runs it's really
interesting I think that the guy who
invented it uh who founded it I think
his name was Jim McCann and his son now
is the CEO and Jim is like a really
interesting guy I've had him on the uh
I've talked to him on the phone a couple
times really fascinating person and his
son is is the CEO now so it's almost
like a really weird family business
another one that falls in this category
have you ever studied Omaha Steaks no so
Omaha do you know what that is no but
that just sounds like exactly what it is
so Omaha Steaks it's a mail order
business uh they sell steaks so if you
want to buy someone like 200 of like
prime rib and filet mignon and chicken
and like bratwurst and [__] you order
from there and they send it to you and
it's an awesome gift and I believe it's
privately owned they make many many
hundreds I wouldn't be surprised if it's
actually north of a billion in revenue
and they were one of the very first
companies to take advantage of internet
marketing and so right when the internet
got popular you would see Omaha Steak
ads everywhere and they were very very
very Progressive with like they're
they're figuring out how to mark Market
on the internet and they're still really
fascinating and it's a really really
interesting company to study I think
it's privately owned you've never I'm
shocked you haven't heard of Omaha
Steaks but you also didn't know who
Dolly Parton was so yeah you're really
shocked yeah exactly but anyway look up
Omaha Steaks you know I I think they're
in like the six or seven hundred million
dollar a year in sales uh range they're
invented or founded in like 1920.
they've been around forever a really
fascinating company to study so they are
they like in are they mostly in stores
or this is like no no no no it's 100
online and you gotta you just have to
call them or it was like a catalog and
you like would order steaks the very
first thing it says the classic gift a
90 package of steaks that's like dude
it's a great gift Neville my my best
friend Neville who's also my neighbor
his mom always is buying them Omaha
Steaks and so whenever he gets an order
of Omaha Steaks we all go to his house
and we like we grill them it's an
awesome gift Omaha Steaks is a wonderful
gift I'm shocked you haven't heard of it
no but I I also feel like this could be
done with like the right uh influencer
partners
like just do a sort of you know a
slightly different version of this this
seems like the type of thing that is uh
you know it's got a pretty good moat
probably because they're like you know
they probably own the the production or
something like that no that's not what
their mode is I would think their moat
is the fact that like it's been around
for so long and so like you saw your
parents gift it to people and then
you're like like oh man what should I
get this guy like oh like I guess like
some [__] Omaha Steaks you know what
I mean it's like See's Candy it's like
why does Warren Buffett like that he's
like I don't know just because like
that's just like the default gift that
men give their wives and like people
have seen their parents do it for years
and then they grow up doing it I don't
know the local Sees Candy here near me
they open up a nursing home in the store
because everybody there is so old it's
incredible genius idea on their part
they're like hey actually it was just a
funeral home in the back
you know it's like one in five tips
[Laughter]
dude See's Candy is pretty whack like uh
I I go and eat it it's [__] but like it
does seem kind of dead at this point but
you know I guess it's like a dating
Center for him like I don't know what's
going on why is about 90 in inside C
scanner that is that just my local one
here no it's always like that but it is
like fire like you get something like
just some truffles you ever had a good
truffle or a turtle I'm all about the
turtles though Turtles a great chocolate
turtle is there's nothing to bat an eye
about but yeah look up Omaha Steaks look
up 100 flowers these are really
interesting companies to study because
like they're also interesting because
you think Omaha Steaks and you like
judge them of like or at least I did I'm
like oh you know it's just like some
Omaha company they can't be that
sophisticated they are incredibly
sophisticated at least in terms of
internet marketing and so they're really
interesting to go and study right
uh okay cool let's uh let's let's cap it
here um by the way there's a bunch of
fun stuff coming so I've got to say
um I want to do the studio tour and
breakdown of how we did this like Studio
change and what you know what we learned
from it what it cost all that good stuff
um I want to do a plan for next year
we're going to do our annual Awards
we're gonna drop the new intro music
we're gonna do all kinds of different
stuff and uh we're gonna talk about
where the pod's going so I want to do
that soon and um
yeah I think I think of the next the
next two weeks I think we're gonna have
some fire podcasts yeah we gotta have
are we gonna do the Millie Awards
yeah Ben let's get Andrew Wilkinson
booked again so we can do the Millie
Awards and we have uh Austin Reef I'm
excited for Austin uh so it's gonna be a
good couple weeks
foreign
[Music]